if you want to make money have kids
every dude who made money had kids
before 30 Elon Musk has 11 kids he had
like five of them before age 32 he
seemed to do well with money next is
Jeff Bezos lot of kids before age 30 the
man should have kids the second he finds
a woman who meets all five archetypes of
long-term mating I once asked Dr Buzz
what's the minimum time you need to know
a girl before you would have a kid with
her and he said probably a year why not
get married have kids so people always
say why don't you have kids I'm like how
do you know I don't have kids some
things should be done not on social
media for safety if you're wellknown
don't put your kids on social media what
are you doing but I'm not a marriage
type love yes marriage is manmade
invention